une mère en larmes qui se présente à
l'école primaire robe de la ville du val
d au texas des parents affolés qui
attendent devant cet établissement de
près de 600 élèves devenue le théâtre
d'une autre fusillade
vers 11h30 du matin une tuerie de masse
a ciblé l'école qui accueille des
enfants du 2e 3e et 4e niveau primaire
aux spurs
le suspect de ce crime haineux agi seul
poursuit le chef de la police de la
ville
la majorité des victimes sont des
enfants le tireur présumé a été
neutralisé lors de l'intervention
policière
le tireur âgé de 18 ans un résident de
la ville un citoyen américain qui se
seraient présentés à l'école à bord d'un
véhicule armé d'une arme de poing et
d'un fusil
parmi les victimes la grand mère du
tireur présumé
une tragédie qui soulève encore le débat
autour des armes à feu pour luigi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait demande le sénateur
démocrate du connecticut qui rappelle la
tuerie de sandy hook la plus violente
des dix dernières années il y a plus de
tueries de masquer des jours dans une
année nos enfants vivent chaque jour
dans la peur à chaque fois qu'il entre
en classe le sénateur du texas tech rose
créée à la politisation de la tragédie
les démocrates et des médias tentent de
politiser le drame et de restreindre les
droits constitutionnels de citoyens
respectueux dit il
les motifs de ce crime demeure inconnue
pour le moment mais le pays est sous le
choc in 1 est mince trop c'est trop en
tant que nation nous devons avoir le
courage d'agir pour nous assurer qu'une
telle chose ne se reproduise pas cech
mollet ce coup double combien d'enfants
combien d'écoliers sont témoins de
drames et voient leurs camarades mourir
somme ou dans un champ de bataille
joe
joe biden a ordonné la mise en berne des
drapeaux à la maison blanche ainsi que
sur les bâtiments et lieux publics des
états unis jusqu'à samedi soir ici s1000
khayat radio canada montréal